and what else
porn cardi b and offset's three-year-old
daughter culture
might just be the cutest little food
influencer like ever is she so cute i
love her on tuesday night the up rapper
shared this sweet clip on her insta
story what is that
yeah that's the 29 year old's grammy
winner's daughter successfully taking us
on a tour through all the food on her
plate
corn
and black
and chicken and everything yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it just me or is anyone else like
starving all of a sudden oh snappity
snap snap but cardi isn't the only one
sharing culture cuteness on social media
earlier this week cardi's hubby and
culture's dad offset posted this sweet
snap of the little one making snow
angels oh yes honey meanwhile culture's
little brother is also making headlines
of course cardi and offset welcomed
their little bundle of joy to the world
on september 4th it's a blessing for god
while the couple has yet to reveal his
name cardi recently tweeted that she's
thinking about having it inked on her
face quote random but i'm one percent
close to tatting my son's name on my
face i really want to do it i mean that
would be a pretty epic way to publicly
announce his name and while the
lovebirds have been pretty private when
it comes to their youngest kiddo they
have shared a few milestones like when
cardi was in disbelief last month that
he's already talking yo you talking
and you just turned four months today
you talking for real
yeah the grammy winner she was shook i'm
not exaggerating
this baby is talking yesterday i was
like you love mommy yeah ask him again
you love mommy and he replied back like
yeah like not even like
it was like yeah but cardian offsets
baby boy isn't a one-hit wonder he did
it again just now like he's watching
coco melon and they're like hey be happy
to say hello hello if you're happy you
know i say hello and then like when they
stop you said ow
yo this is crazy i need a camera in this
room 24 7 a sign and baby boy he might
just be a baby genius because in
december cardi tweeted that at just
three months old he was already
mastering the art of eating quote my son
holding his bottle with both his hands
already and while the couple has kept
their littlest one's face off social
media the i like it rapper did give fans
a glimpse in a 30th birthday shout out
post dedicated to her husband i already
fell in love uh the way that he was a
dad he's really good he's really good
and don't blink or you'll miss their
newborn in this instapost from december
showing off their over-the-top christmas
decor
[Music]